sehr geehrte damen und herren ich
begrüße es ist ja herzlich zum
pressegespräch mit
verteidigungsministerium klaudia tanner
und dem für die stellung im
verteidigungsministerium zuständigen
general harald nograsek und ich darf die
frau verteidigungsministerin versuchen
zu beginnen
generalmajor sehr geehrte damen und
herren jede österreichische man bis zum
alter von 35 jahren ist wehrpflichtig
und hat daher die stellungs untersuchung
des bundesheeres zu durchlaufen
jahr für jahr werden durch die ärzte
psychologen psychologen und anderes
medizinisches personal des heeres in
sechs stellung straßen in etwa 40.000
männer bei dieser stellung auf herz und
nieren untersucht und wenn ich das sage
sehr geehrte damen und herren dass man
meine ich das auch so nämlich im
wahrsten sinne des wortes die jungen
männer werden beginnend mit einer
umfassenden physiologischen untersuchung
auch psychologisch durchgecheckt wir
leisten damit einen enormen einen großen
beitrag zur gesundheit zur
volksgesundheit
wenn ich hier ein allgemeines beispiel
nennen darf dann möchte ich anmerken
dass wir jahr für jahr leichte aber auch
sehr schwere erkrankungen bei den
stellungspflichtigen erkennen erkennen
müssen um so durch die sehr frühe
diagnose auch etliche leben halten
konnten
es ist mir ein bedürfnis mich an dieser
stelle bei den mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern unserer stellungs häuser zu
bedanken denn sie leisten weil ich einen
großartigen job und ich möchte an dieser
stelle auch eines klarstellen wir werden
es nicht zulassen dass diese mitarbeiter
irgendwie für den rückstand zu dem ich
gleich kommen darf verantwortlich
gemacht werden denn sie leisten wirklich
einen tollen job davon konnte ich mich
und ich weiß dass der eine oder die
andere von ihnen auch schon mit dabei
war in unseren stellung
rassen wirklich eine großartige arbeit
die korona krise hält uns er seit
nunmehr einem jahr unter einigen monaten
auf trab und wir müssen wir alle müssen
tag für tag mit den schwerwiegenden
folgen dieser krise leben und beinahe
jeder mensch in diesem land hat
mittlerweile verluste hinnehmen müssen
sei es in der wirtschaft sei es im job
oder im privaten leben jan viele
menschen haben auch geliebte mitmenschen
und familienmitglieder verloren
jan sowie in vielen bereichen in beinahe
allen bereichen so blieb auch unser
bundesheer und auch darstellungs betrieb
nicht unberührt
versetzen wir uns vielleicht gemeinsam
noch einmal in das vorige jahr zurück an
dem beginn der krise als niemand von uns
wusste was da jetzt auf uns zukommt und
auch die expertinnen und experten nicht
gewusst haben wie wir mit dem ganzen
umgehen sollen
im lichte dieser umstände und auch der
verordnungen des gesundheitsministeriums
unter liegend haben wir dann zum
damaligen zeitpunkt den stellungs
betrieb für zwölf wochen einstellen
müssen
es war zu diesem zeitpunkt zum damaligen
zeitpunkt anders nicht möglich
es hat dann unglaublich viel an
eigeninitiative gegeben der
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter und
schlussendlich haben wir es geschafft
die stellungs häuser unter strengsten
kowitz schutzbestimmungen und
hygienemaßnahmen wieder zu öffnen
seit diesem tag sind die stellungs
häuser geöffnet und der betrieb findet
durchgehend stadt außer natürlich dort
wo aktuell etwas passierte so man einen
coup fall zu verzeichnen hat wir hatten
aber zu diesem zeitpunkt bereits einen
rückstand von 13.000 jungen männern
dieser rückstau ist nunmehr bereits auf
1900 reduziert sehr geehrte damen und
herren das ist nicht da einfach so
passiert weil wir weitergemacht haben
wie bisher sondern weil die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter mit
hochdruck am abbau dieses rückstandes
gearbeitet haben wir die zeiten und tage
der stellung ausgedehnt haben
urlaubssperre verhängt haben ärztinnen
und ärzte und psychologen psychologinnen
aus anderen bereichen des heeres in die
stellungs häuser zur personellen
unterstützung verlegt haben und auch an
dieser stelle noch einmal
stellvertretend an den herrn
generalmajor ein ganz großes dankeschön
es sie zum jetzigen zeitpunkt so aus
dass in kärnten und der steiermark der
rückstau bereits erledigt ist in wien
niederösterreich und oberösterreich wird
das nächste oder übernächste woche der
fall sein und in tirol dann in der
kalenderwoche 20 das heißt also mitte
mai in etwa der jahrgang 2003 und denen
es in diesem jahr geht kommt er nun
sofort zum zug und wird jetzt bereits
untersucht wir sind bemüht dass wir auch
den letzten teil des rückstaus wirklich
so schnell wie möglich abarbeiten
ich sage aber auch offen dass es
einzelne fälle ohne zweifel gegeben hat
und gibt wo es zu sehr mühsamen und
unangenehmen verschiebungen gekommen ist
und kommt das tut mir persönlich sehr
leid und das muss im rahmen unserer
möglichkeiten weitgehend auch verhindert
werden
wir sind immer bemüht und ich glaube das
ist das wichtige uns gerade um
einzelfälle die begründen dringend ihren
stellungs termin brauchen dann auch
individuelle und maßgeschneiderte
lösungen zu finden
wie geht es nun weiter wir werden wie
gesagt den rückstau stück für stück
abarbeiten wir werden die
stellungspflichtigen per brief und über
unsere website bundesheer punktete
laufend informieren wir werden auch
selbst
verständlich die jeweiligen gemeinden
und städte am laufen halten denn eines
an dieser stelle auch gesagt das
wichtigste ist und muss sonst die
gesundheit der stellungspflichtigen
seien und daher werden wir auch
weiterhin auf sehr strenge um strikte
hygiene maßnahmen setzen
was haben wir noch getan und was machen
wir noch wir sind intensiv beschäftigt
mit der modernisierung unserer stellungs
häuser unsere stellungs straßen
ich darf ihnen hier einiges an
investitionssummen nennen wir haben in
st pölten graz um den klagenfurt jeweils
1,4 millionen euro investiert in
innsbruck 5 millionen euro und in linz
findet derzeit noch die generalsanierung
stadt unsere stellungs hauses um 4
millionen
ja und da in wien auch ein wichtiger
punkt da planen wir die errichtung eines
neuen stellungs hauses in der
französischen kaserne
da geht es um eine investitionssumme von
11 millionen euro
wir haben vieles zu tun auch was
baumaßnahmen anbelangt aber insbesondere
was den abbau des rückstaus bei den
stellungspflichtigen anbelangt ich danke
ihnen dankeschön bezirk in ramallah sehr
geehrte damen und herren damit sie
ungefähr eine idee haben was die zahlen
betrifft
im jahr 20 21 im jahr 20 21 werden wir
den geburtsjahrgang 2003 darstellung zu
führen
geburtsjahrgang 2003 umfasst etwa 37.400
stellungspflichtige zu diesem geburtstag
an drei kommen wie gesagt die herren des
geburtsjahrganges zweiter zu wir gehen
davon aus dass wir im jahr 20 21 alle
unsere rückstände sofern kubik nicht
möglicherweise in mehreren wellen was
wir nicht hoffen auf uns zukommt
abarbeiten so dass die jungen herren
jedenfalls keine probleme mit ihren
karrieren haben jedenfalls ihre berufe
ihre lehren ihre studien beginnen können
und das ist im prinzip das ziel für
dieses jahr wir sind hier sehr gut
unterwegs wir sind hier wir sind hier
grundsätzlich in verbindung mit der 79
bezirken wenn sie so wollen und mit den
2095 gemeinden in österreich unserer 6
unsere sechs stellung straßen und
insgesamt neun ergänzungs abteilungen
sind im permanenten kontakt mit den
bürgermeistern und auch im kontakt mit
dem jungen staatsbürgern und unser
interesse ist natürlich vor allem auch
hinsichtlich nicht nur unsere
organisation sondern auch hinsichtlich
der gesamtwirtschaftlichen lage und das
arbeitsmarkt ist dass die jungen herren
so schnell wie möglich dann nach dem
grundwehrdienst in ihre studien- oder
arbeiten eintreten können
der zivildienst ist etwas was natürlich
für uns auch von relevanz ist
aber wir konzentrieren uns vor allem
darauf dass wir die jungen männer mal in
der stellung system bringen und im
stellung system optimale optimale
service lässt und bieten die jungen
männer können in weiterer folge die frau
bundesminister hat das bereits angeführt
auf der website des bundesheers
jedenfalls die detail-informationen
schon seit längerem empfangen die
stellung und machen wie wird ein oder
andere sie vielleicht kennen wird in
form eines plakates muss der letztes
jahr ausgesetzt werden
aufgrund dessen dass wir die den kobe
kobe fälle gehabt haben und ansonsten
kann ich sagen die frau bundesminister
hat es bereits eingeführt wir haben alle
anstrengungen unternommen seit den
letzten juni in vor strukturell
personell alles aufzustocken wir form
zum beispiel in den sechs stellungs
häusern weil mit insgesamt 200 plänen
für unterkünfte für nassräume etc
es sind plexiglas wieder aufgestellt
worden wir
die kobik vor testungen und wir haben
auch die fsb zwei masken flächendeckend
und durchgehend dennoch kann es uns
passieren dass cobit fälle in die
stellungs häuser kommen so wie wir das
in tirol erlebt haben und dann gibt es
möglicherweise wieder einschränken und
aber ansonsten gehen wir davon aus dass
wir unser system weiter franken und
nachdem die bundesregierung in den sehr
guten impfplan hat dazu führen wird dass
wir mitte des jahres den großteil der
bevölkerung durch gift haben sehen wir
da gehen wir davon aus dass die
herausforderungen für darstellungssystem
weniger werden
danke schön ich darf nun um ihre fragen
zu suchen und das sieht man anzeichen
bitten die poller bitte ich hätte zwei
fragen einerseits frau ministerin sie
haben individuelle lösungen angekündigt
was genau müssen die burschen da machen
die da betroffen sind welchen welchen
weg müssen die gehen und sie haben drei
bundesländer nicht genannt wenn ich
aufgepasst habe richtig salzburg
vorarlberg und wundern gab es dort gar
keinen rückstau oder ist er so groß dass
der noch länger dauert bis abgebaut ist
ja danke für die frage ich da vielleicht
mit dem zweiten teil anfangen es gibt es
sechs stellungs häuser und sechs
stellung straßen
daher sind diese bundesländer eben eben
nicht nicht genannt worden
was meinen wir mit individuallösungen
wir meinen dass der stellungspflichtige
sich über unsere bundesheer seite
informieren kann über das jeweils für
ihn zuständige militärkommando
beziehungsweise die dortige ergänzungs
abteilung die auch mit einer
telefonnummer versehen ist man kann das
per telefon per e-mail machen auf
natürlich auch auf schriftliche art und
weise und dort seinen wunsch kundtun wir
wollen dass das von mensch zu mensch
eben passiert die zuständigkeit liegt
eben in den jeweiligen militärkommanden
und ist auch auf unserer homepage
aufgelistet das sind ja ganz
unterschiedliche dinge einer wie es ja
auch später machen dann die stellung
weil er vorher seine ausbildung geben
vollenden will wichtig ist auch wer
bereits eine ausbildung begonnen hat wir
haben interesse daran dass jeder junge
mann diese ausbildung die er gewählt hat
was auch immer das ist auch fertig macht
und der wird dazu daher in diesem
zeitraum so er das nicht will nicht von
unser herangezogen sondern erst danach
weil ganz offen auch wir sind zum
beispiel froh wenn wir fertig
ausgebildet wird zum beispiel juristen
haben oder ärzte wie gesagt die
wehrpflicht geht ja bis zum alter von 35
jahren
frau ministerin für jene die vielleicht
nachteile dadurch haben dass sie eben in
diesen rückstau gekommen sind wird da
gibt es gibt es da irgendwelche
erleichterungen und vielleicht wenn sie
schon da sind könnten sie auch sagen
zustellung da geht es auch um
tauglichkeit
da gab es ja neue tauglichkeitskriterien
was ist daraus geworden
unter den herrn generalmajor habe ich
noch die frage in diesen bundesländern
zum beispiel im osten wo jetzt der lock
down ist gibt es da irgendwelche
besonderen vorkehrungen ist das
irgendwie anders geregelt durch den
anderen bundesländern
ich beginne mit dem ersten teil der
frage diese 1930 jungen männer die
sozusagen jetzt noch im rückstand sind
denen würde ich ihm vorschlagen sich
umgehend wenn sie den wunsch haben
sofort eben zur stellung zu kommen
beim jeweiligen militärkommando zu
melden auf eben telefonische art und
weise oder per e mail und ihren wunsch
im bekannt zu geben das war eben gemeint
mit auch einem grundwehrdienst nach maß
aber was den zeitlichen rahmen neben
anbelangt das bringt mich zum zweiten
teil
frage frau strebel wenn es um die
tauglichkeitskriterien geht wir haben
wir seit diesem jahr schon nach den
neuen tauglichkeitsstufen auch beurteilt
was wir jetzt sehen ist dass die
geschätzte anzahl der zusätzlichen in
etwa 2000 grundwehrdiener
beziehungsweise so muss ich eigentlich
sagen der tauglichen 2000 in etwa
ausmachen wird das sehen wir jetzt nach
den ersten wochen beziehungsweise
monaten wonach die insights kriterien
schon geurteilt worden ist und davon
werden sich so hoffen wir in etwa 1200
zusätzliche eben für den grundwehrdienst
entscheiden und in etwa 800 für den
zivildienst entscheiden frage darf ich
antworten wien niederösterreich
burgenland das sind jene bundesländer
die sowohl in sankt pölten als auch in
wien die stellung zu untersuchen haben
in den stellungsfehler und sowohl in
sankt pölten als auch in wien wie vorhin
angeführt habe sind alle
sicherheitsvorkehrungen getroffen von
abtrennungen abstand halten fb2 masken
nakowitz vortests dort wo wir die
möglichkeit hatten das sanitätspersonal
impfen zu lassen haben wir das getan so
dass der junge stellungspflichtige der
möglicherweise einen bezirk kommt wie
wiener neustadt durchaus den austritt
aus wiener neustadt sich selber
organisieren muss in dem im prinzip die
überprüfung macht aber an sonst
planmäßig das stellungs haus sowohl in
wien als in sankt pölten erreichen kann
und insofern haben wir alle maßnahmen
schon getroffen
nicht wissend dass also diese
dramatische situation in den bezirken in
ostösterreich passieren könnte also wir
haben wir sind vorbereitet wir aus
unserer sicht sind wir zwei schritte
voraus und können sicherstellen dass die
jungen herren aus diesen bezirken auch
entsprechend in die stellungs häuser
kommen können und wie sie wissen
möglicherweise die bürgermeister sind ja
auch eingebunden
teilweise sind diese diese stellungs
abläufe
bürger mehr es gibt bürgermeister die
busse organisieren und die jungen
stellungspflichtigen dann dorthin
bringen und ich gehe davon aus dass die
bürgermeister wissen welche abstände
einzuhalten sind ich selber bin pendler
von wiener neustadt nach wien ich pendle
seit dem 16 märz jeden tag nach wien und
versuche auch mich dort richtig zu
verhalten und wie sie wissen die
österreichische bevölkerung ist
eigentlich sehr sehr diszipliniert mit
den masken also ich hatte ja ich habe in
der eisenbahn in der u-bahn noch niemand
gesehen ohne maske und wir schauen sehr
sehr penibel in den stellungs häusern
darauf dass das alles seine ordnung hat
uns so wie die frau bundesministerin
gesagt hat das ist eine
gesundenuntersuchung und wir sind hoch
daran interessiert dass die jungen
männer alle durchlaufen können zur
tauglichkeit darf ich vielleicht noch
ergänzend zur frau bundesministerin der
2002er jahren wie sie wissen war nicht
betroffen von den tauglichkeitskriterien
also die herren die jetzt noch zur
zustellung kommen werden diesem regime
nicht unterworfen aber die 2000 2003
jacken gleich nach dem neuen regime und
beginnt davon aus so wie die frau
bundesministerin das gesagt hat dass wir
etwa 55 prozent derer die wir aus diesem
system bekommen für den grundwehrdienst
bekommen werden und etwa 45 prozent so
wie bisher für den zivildienst und die
zahl die wir annehmen ist etwa 2000 es
ist läuft bereits und wir haben zu
sorgen die ersten tauglichen schon die
teils deutlichen ja wohl gibt es weitere
fragen
muss doch was die bürger sind frau
minister ich habe vor drei wochen bei
der wiener neustadt corona test straße
habe ich ihnen zwei fragen habe ich
gestellt ich möchte ich diese zwei
fragen noch einmal stehen
wir sehen den corona seiten dass wir
bundeswehreinsätze viele junge leute
brauchen ja auslandeinsätze katastrophen
sektionsleiter und es gibt 32 berufe im
bundesheer dazu macht ihre kommunikation
stabstelle großer kampagnen der wirt
millionen euro steuergelder gegeben und
da wird die migranten medien nur
serbische medien berücksichtigt und die
muslimische medien wie wir ja wie aus
österreich in österreich eine zukunft
werden die nicht berichtigt ja und ich
hab da mal ne frage gestellt beim
interview ihnen habe ich mir versucht
mit job zu machen ich könnte keine
antwort bekommen können von ihnen weil
während interview ist ihre stabschef
hineingegangen hat verhindert diese
interio und auch der ire pressesprecher
hat verhindert manager zu machen in ein
demokratisches land in unser land
österreich und unser interview wurde mit
irgendwelche signale hornist sabotiert
worden
unsere interieur wurde sabotiert in
österreich in dem job in österreich was
sagen sie mein erster güte um das geht
hier um die stellung und ich darf
weitere fragen zum thema stellung
ersuchen möglichkeit der frage nämlich
auch insofern weil sie etwas wichtiges
auch gesagt haben
nicht nur dass die aktuellen einsätze
des österreichischen bundesheeres
anbelangt wir haben über 4000
soldatinnen und soldaten im in- und im
ausland im einsatz
gerade mit der koroma krise beschäftigt
mit den unterschiedlichen einsätzen bei
contact racing bei den test straßen auch
dort wo bezirke eben die besonders
betroffen sind abgetrennt werden müssen
und da wird wirklich großartige und
unverzichtbare arbeit arbeit geleistet
und dennoch haben wir auch anderes und
tun wir auch anderes das ist richtig wir
bilden sogar in über 40 verschiedenen
lehrberufen aus und bieten hier der
jugend unglaublich viele möglichkeiten
die man auch auf unserer homepage auf
karriere.at nachlesen kann
und selbstverständlich versehen wir
dieses auch mit den entsprechenden
werblichen maßnahmen sei es um offene
stellen bei lehrstellen geht oder sei es
drum wo wir eben informieren über unsere
aktuellen einsätze unserer aktuellen
corona einsätze aber allenfalls offene
lehrstellen noch in den verschiedensten
bereichen das tun wir nach einem
vorgegebenen plant das beinhaltet
selbstverständlich auch inserate und ich
würde wie ich schon in wiener neustadt
gesagt habe als wir uns vom großartigen
einsatz unserer soldatinnen und soldaten
in wiener neustadt bei den testungen
überzeugen kunden dann können wir sehr
gerne
im anschluss daran mit unserem
mitarbeiter der für die
kommunikationsarbeit und die aufteilung
der inserate zuständig ist sehr gerne
sprechen
es war keine weiteren fragen zum thema
stellung gibt beende hiermit die
pressekonferenz und bedanke mich für
kommen dankeschön